he's coding nurse get five cc's of
parallelograms and one Sega Genesis
I've got some medical laughs analysis
for you people you don't have a double
chin what you do have is bad posture so
all you need to do is two steps bring
your shoulders up back and down bring
your chin slightly forward and then
slightly down and look at the difference
then
that's backwards no you want to keep
your shoulders open chest open facing
the world ready to take on challenges I
don't know if you notice I've started
working out again I'm really sore and
this really hurts things Tick Tock made
me buy this is a phone charger that
supposedly leads you to the strongest
power source in the entire house oh no
oh we went to a mitochondria Powerhouse
of the cell touche
golf clap for that
[Music]
this gives new meaning to walking your
dog honestly my dog walk like that I
wouldn't put it on a leash I would just
say like look my dog walks next to me I
would hold its paw when you finally get
that long white coat and your boys
invite you over to watch the game
students wear short lab coats white
coats and doctors wear long ones so if
you ever see people in short white coats
walking around they could be students I
can't take it off
take it off
and take it off I can't
take it off I can't take it off
like
take it off again you don't want to take
it off I remember when I was a student
and I went through my white coat
ceremony and I had my white coat for the
first time I remember pulling up to
Coney Island Hospital parking my car two
blocks away and proudly wearing the
white coat as I walked the two blocks
from my car when really I still have
like seven years of education left and
I'm like
this is gonna be stressful do you
remember that patient you saw yesterday
for chest pain
foreign
[Music]
doctor anything helps
yes how come I ran into her today she's
doing so much better thanks for your
care it's so true I will literally have
someone from my office staff say oh you
know that patient you saw of something
and the anxiety level starts creeping up
like did something bad happen did they
file a complaint and it's not because
that happens often in fact that's really
rare for it to happen but it like
there's this fear that you did something
wrong because you want to do right by
everybody it is scary you want the best
for your patients and as a doctor You're
Gonna Miss stuff you're gonna
misdiagnose things because patients
conditions don't always present so
clearly they take time to develop part
of the art of medicine oh I have such a
bad headache I have essential oils is
this safe of course doctors use it
essential oil cures anything here 30
seconds keep breathing it in burning my
eye that means it's working closer you
have to believe it he's like
chloroforming her with the essential oil
or it won't work
almost forgot the crystal just keep
breathing I don't want to do this
anymore he threw in a Reiki Crystal
feel better my headache's gone I told
you wait is that grapefruit yeah why I'm
allergic
so I don't have an essential oil for
that he's gonna need an EpiPen and
luckily he's not over the Atlantic Ocean
if you haven't seen that story of mine
link down below salmon implants are made
to withstand almost anything watch me as
I try to break it
laughs
oh what
okay I don't know if this person is a
legitimate doctor I don't know what the
purpose of fighting that saline implant
was I don't know the durability of
saline implants but I'd like to think
they're quite durable I don't know if
they're made interested in turn like
that and I've actually had patients come
in who had an implant that ruptured
saline implant the one experience I've
had was a patient came in and she walked
into this like the edge of her car door
and like she like kind of turned in and
didn't expect a door to be there and it
punctured the implant ooh that hurt but
we right away got her an urgent plastic
surgery evalina got figured out
sweetheart there's no need to worry you
won't feel a thing why would anyone on
Tick Tock tries to play a female
character they put in disgusting white
towel on their head and they're like oh
that somehow represents female hair
thing
if you ever enter a pediatrician's
office or a family medicine doctor's
office there is screams go
es part of the process because children
are naturally nervous they get scared
there's strange or anxiety this is part
of normal development and when we get
vaccines even if it doesn't hurt that
much it's scary imagine a stranger
bringing a needle to you so yes there
are screams all the time my strategy is
to give the child a distraction and
sometimes a present before I do anything
not I'll give you a lollipop if you
listen but here's a lollipop so you
listen I just want to to know that I
miss you and I love you can't wait for
this show to be over so that I
touch people
no honestly like I want to go back this
sounds weird but to touching people I
want to go back to shaking hands Insider
I don't know if you follow it it's an
Instagram account they recently posted
that like handshakes are about to become
a thing of the past no it's not Insider
handshakes are an important part of
non-verbal communication for humans it's
how we trust others it's how we show we
have no weapons back in the day but it's
like a way to communicate with someone a
handshake tells a lot about that person
about your relationship about how you're
going to communicate and the fact that
there's a pandemic going on sure we can
suspend it now but it doesn't mean we
need to be afraid of all germs and
become germaphobic pandemic no
handshakes no pandemic handshakes see
how that works we don't have to swing
the pendulum the complete other way
every time something happens
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
patient protection act
health information patient protection
accountability Act
health information protection
accountability Act
is down below
[Music]
no no no no when I was in the hospital
and I worked the 36 hour shift I wasn't
like
in fact when you're leaving the hospital
after a 24-hour 36 hour shift you're
literally walking with your eyes half
closed body fluids all over your scrubs
placenta on your shoe if you're working
in the OB Department residency is a hard
time there would be a period where I
wouldn't see my friends for a month
they're like where were you I'm like I
see you life six days a week 18 hour
days tough good morning sexy doctors and
welcome to hospital six of you will die
this season and I don't want to catch
any of you having sex in the on-call
room unless it's with me he's coding
nurse get five cc's of parallelograms
and one Sega Genesis
the chest compressions are like this and
she's getting parallelograms and Sega
Genesis which is the first ever video
game console I've owned God that's
brilliant medical dramas are so
innocuous oh
are they cutting into it with a
Cuisinart knife that is not an approved
medical piece of technology that's made
for chicken and steaks
that was a good flap I'm not gonna lie
solid flap
was that supposed to be a delivery of
macaronis those are little macaronis
how did they get the macaronis inside
the banana you guys are gonna probably
laugh at me those aren't macaronis right
those are like fettuccine's or
God what's like the long pasta called
it starts with a z no it doesn't let's
give another huge thank you to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video the
link is down below click it to get up to
three months free and if you want to
know how I got into med school click
here for this video and if you want to
see how I stay productive with some easy
tips for you click here for productivity
101 video as always stay happy and
healthy which one are you clicking on
foreign
[Music]